here's a picture a very simple picture
but your next line is
well why should i subscribe to the new
water view
and quite simply it's to attain regular
jojo content upload it straight into
your youtube feed hello and welcome to
jojo 101 the series that breaks down
everyone and everything in the realm of
jojo's bizarre adventure and today we
are going to be diving into one of the
more prolific and influential
protagonists within this grand saga the
absurdly charismatic joseph joestar
joseph joesta is the second main
protagonist of jojo's bizarre adventure
whose tenure primarily consisted of
helming part two battle tenancy however
he would go on to play a great role
within future parts and generations
in terms of lineage joseph is the
grandson of our original protagonist
jonathan joster
and the son of george joe star ii
however unlike jonathan joseph presents
a much less gentlemanly take on life as
he is quite volatile and confrontational
as well as a generally loud and comedic
persona with that said joseph is also a
natural-born genius who is almost
exclusively able to win his various
battles against significantly more
powerful opponents
via pure wit which is probably most
prominently on display within his secret
technique which to the untrained eye
consists of joseph quickly running and
comically retreating from combat
however its true purpose is to survey
the environment around him and lure his
opponents into more unfavorable
conditions as a classical joe star
though joseph was raised in england
primarily by his grandmother erena as
well as his grandmother's close friend
robert eo speedwagon this was due to a
family tragedy whereby his father was
killed and joseph's mother was forced
into hiding
after exacting retribution for george's
murder but very interestingly young
joseph inherited extraordinary potential
for using harmon and by the time he made
his debut appearance in battle tendency
he was already an extraordinarily
proficient wielder despite never having
received formal
training and so at the age of 18 joseph
had grown into the stacked physique of
his genetic namesake and his adventure
would begin in 1938 when he and erina
left england on a trip to new york
and once their shenanigans was easy
enough to find as joseph encountered a
fearsome vampire and not just any
vampire but a former ally of his
grandfather jonathan
and after defeating mr vampire also
known as straitso joseph was alerted to
the existence of the mysterious man in
the pillar which threatened to be an
even more powerful foe than the vampires
created by the stone masks in addition
to this joseph was informed of the
supposed death of speedwagon and so he
went to mexico in order to investigate
during which time he crossdressed and
discovered a nazi research facility you
know the standard story beats and inside
joseph found an alive and well speed
wagon as well as santana a recently
awoken pillar man who completely dwarfed
joseph in terms of general abilities
however with the help of strawheim
santana was eventually defeated by being
exposed to the sun
a stunning weakness that the pillarmen
shared with vampires very unfortunately
though there were three other pillar men
still in existence in this world and so
speedwagon ferry joseph to rome
in order to undergo hamon training at
which point joseph met caesar antonio
zeppeli the son of will antonio zeppeli
who taught harmon to jonathan joestar
and joseph and caesar
they didn't quite see eye to eye in
their dynamic though primarily because
these two had very
polarizing personalities and yet at the
same time they were so
incredibly similar in fact on one
occasion when they were both playing
poker both joseph and caesar attempted
to cheat to hilarious consequences
however this dynamic would also forge a
strong bond which occurred after they
had both undergone further ham on
training before that though joseph did
manage to form another more unorthodox
bond at this time with a pill a man by
the name of wamu
after discovering all three remaining
pillarmen in a secret roman cave both
joseph and caesar were easily defeated
by wamu and on the verge of being killed
however joseph was able to use his
trademark cunning to appeal to wamu's
sense of warrior's honor and a lust for
challenge by informing
wamu that he had yet to complete his sum
on training and that wamu could only
prove that he was the superior warrior
by beating joseph at his best and you
know what that gambit worked
joseph was spared however to prevent him
from simply running away
both wamu and another pillar man ac dc
inserted rings containing poison into
jose's body that were set to dissolve in
a month's time meaning that joseph would
have to become strong and skillful
enough to defeat at least two pillar men
within a mere month
quite the tough ask but in aid of this
joseph traveled to venice with caesar
and they underwent intensive hormone
training under the tutelage of lisa lisa
oops spoiler alert also turns out to be
joseph's mother although joseph was
rather unaware of this when he was
spying on her naked that one time
some very oedipus-y sort of stuff
happening here in battle tendency but
it's also worth noting that joseph would
meet a lady of his own in venice being
lisa lisa's servant susie q but more
about her in a bit because three weeks
after joseph's training began the
grounds were invaded by ac dc who would
be defeated thanks to a series of
fantastically implemented
ideas from joseph and he managed to
attain the antidote for one of his
internal poison ring things
from here joseph caesar and lisa lisa
traveled to switzerland to confront wamu
and the leader of the pillarman cars
which would lead to caesar's tragic
death at the hands of wamu and quite
possibly the most emotional moment of
the entirety of the life and times of
joseph joestar where after a profound
moment of despair joseph once again
resolved to defeat wamu which he would
in a
roman chariot style jewel which was was
unique and it would involve a whole host
of
other improbably well thought out ideas
which really is the strong suit of
joseph but even after beating wamu and
saving his life from the deadly deadly
poison
we still had cars a being who had now
found his way up into impossible power
and after putting a thing in another
thing he
had now become the ultimate life form
and in order to defeat this final pillar
man
joseph led cars to a volcano whereby a
mighty enhanced haman eruption occurred
and joseph knocked cars out of earth's
orbit where he would go on to float
through the universe
for all eternity and then later on
joseph went on to crash his own funeral
as well as marry susie q
thus bringing a rather happy ending to
battle tenancy however joseph's journey
was ever so far from done and he would
continue the joe style line by having a
daughter named holly whom joseph
treasured more than anyone else in this
world which is why when holly grew up
and moved to japan with her husband
sadao joseph developed a general dislike
of japanese people
although with that said he would go on
to have an affair with a japanese woman
by the name of tomoko higashikata an
affair that would produce yet
another jojo but before we get into that
at the age of 65 joseph jostar very
mysteriously manifested an ability known
as a stand which in this case was named
hermit purple
a funky little existence that allowed
joseph to spawn thorny vines which were
capable of conducting hamon as well and
yeah it sounds pretty underwhelming but
in the hands of a trickster like joseph
joestar it became
quite an effective utility the most
important feature of homopurple though
is that it allowed joseph to engage in
divination by using an object like say a
camera or a tv
and with a target in mind he could then
attain a picture of said target
however the reason for joseph developing
this ability had to do with dio the
immortal rival of joseph's grandfather
who had resurfaced back into the world
having
fixed his head to jonathan's body and
presenting the greatest enemy that the
joestar family had ever faced however
joseph was not the only one to develop a
stand out of nowhere as he received a
call from holly stating that her son and
joseph's grandson jotaro had been
possessed by an evil spirit and so at
the age of 67
joseph traveled to japan and thus began
the events of part three stardust
crusaders upon arriving in japan joseph
discovered his grandson in prison having
manifested a stance that would become
known as star platinum an existence far
more powerful than joseph's home at
purple and after an altercation joseph
explained their family's past with dio
as well as recruited jotaro in an effort
to stop him a big push towards this so
was that holly had also manifested a
stand which she did not possess the
spirit to harness and so it began slowly
killing her giving joseph and jotaro an
estimated 50 days to find and kill dear
theoretically then breaking his link to
the jostar family
and saving holly on this journey though
joseph would be joined by his good
friend and colleague mohammad abdul and
these two had a good working
relationship in fact avdor was the
individual who
taught joseph about the very nature of
stance also amongst their group was a
high school student oriaki kokuin a man
who had been previously brainwashed by
dio
or brain bugged brain infested i don't
know what you would actually call it but
if every member within this group joseph
probably had the least
on-screen interaction with kakuin
however the two had a clear respect for
one another and trusted each other
implicitly
furthermore joseph had a tendency to
bombard kaku in with jokes because this
polite school student was the most
tolerant of his foolishness
shortly after their departure joseph and
the group were also joined by
jean-pierre palnar a personality that
was much more let's say
agreeable with joseph due to his goofy
nature and our final crusader would be
iggy a stray dog and stand user as well
as all around good boy and so this pack
would travel across the world having
tracked dio to egypt in an adventure
that would reveal how joseph had truly
changed over the years
most evidently joseph no longer
possessed his aggressively energetic and
borderline arrogant nature and he was
instead much more calm and calculated
for the most part anyway he was also
demonstrably much more worldly and
mature as well as capable of acting as a
leader whereas our young joseph was much
more of a rogue agent however he did
still retain his clownish nature
and often used it for the purposes of
comedy in part three although with that
said he was also able to provide
something of a role model for his
grandson jotaro they say something of a
role model because their personalities
were
polar opposites however in the end these
two developed an extraordinary bond
which would prove to be a formidable
team going up against whatever
unfortunate soldiers happen to cross
their path and that brings us to dio who
by this point possessed a stand known as
the world which allowed him to stop time
briefly
and made effectively the entire band of
crusaders powerless against him which
was displayed to us when dio mercilessly
killed kakyoin but not before he was
able to send a very valuable
message to joseph informing out once
plucky joestar of dio's time-related
abilities
simply knowing dio's power would not
grant joseph any advantage whatsoever
though and after warning his grandson
joseph was stabbed through the throat
and subsequently had his blood sucked
out by dio thus killing him
or not after george roy successfully
defeated dio he engaged the medics of
the speedwagon foundation to perform a
blood transfusion from dio's body to
joseph's a process that miraculously
worked
and brought joseph back to life and even
in this the most serious of situations
joseph's first thought was to play a
prank on his grandson pretending that he
was deo and some classic
joseph joe star right there but on a
more somber note joseph and jotaro
successfully rid this world of dio by
burning his body with the rising sun
whilst also taking the time to mourn
their lost companions
then the three remaining crusaders would
exchange a heartfelt goodbye with joseph
and jotura returning to japan in order
to find a fully recovered holly which
brought an end to part three
of jojo's bizarre adventure and while
this would be the end of joseph's tenure
in a primary role his life would go on
and on however over the next decade age
absolutely caught up with him joseph
began suffering a wide array of both
physical and mental conditions but
during this time joseph also lamented on
his affair which had produced a son
named josuke higashikata whom joseph
added to his will and attempted to use
hermit purple to attain a picture of
however what emerged was quite an
ominous photo after which jojoro
embarked on a journey to mario in order
to investigate thus beginning part four
diamond is unbreakable although
eventually a very frail 79 year old
joseph droster would also travel to the
small japanese town where he would meet
his son josuke for the first time and
while josuke expressly forbade joseph
from contacting his mother tomoko this
father and son would eventually form a
bond of their own
primarily through an incident involving
an invisible baby the baby that would
take quite well to the elderly joseph
and he would later adopt and name she's
a good joster an act that would further
estrange joseph from his wife susa q who
was already livid about his affair
and would likely believe that shizuka
was yet another secret love child of
joseph and as such joseph would spend
the majority of his time in part 4
caring for shizuka
until the threat in moria was defeated
at which point he left the town with
shusika and jotaro and that really is
more or less the end of the adventures
of joseph joestar some more fun facts
about joseph joestar
despite his last appearance being in
part 4 araki did confirm in an interview
that joseph was likely still alive by
the time we reached part 6
being stone ocean and this would make
him 91 at the time of those events
as we've just seen joseph led quite the
bizarre life having taken part in
defeating an immortal vampire as well as
the ultimate life form but to add to
that joseph has also survived no
less than four plane crashes two of
which being in battle tendency and two
of which were in stardust crusaders and
finally a truly useless fact
in part three there is a running gag
with joseph's prosthetic hand where it
will be periodically damaged or even
destroyed
only to appear later being completely
intact without any explanation
whatsoever but that pretty much does it
for joseph joestar but what do you guys
think please do let me know down in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
jojo content then please do go and check
out some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel for regular
jojo wonder delivered straight
to your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time